the commons for prime minister's
questions to get the sack yeah
yeah Mr Speaker the Home Secretary made
an error judgment but she recognized her
mistake and took accountability for her
actions but she has now set out
transparently in detail a full sequence
of events in a letter to the labor chair
of the home Affairs select committee
offered to share relevant documents with
the chair and she is now getting on with
the job cracking down on crime defending
our borders something I know the party
opposite has no interest in supporting
[Music]
my 19 year old congleton can situent
Murray who has been in care much of her
life
has worked long and hard by child mining
in other ways to save three thousand six
hundred pounds to help support herself
at University
Mario now faces her university studies
with no savings and no means of
recovering them because it has all been
stolen from her in a few seconds by a
heartless scammer pretending to be her
bank what Assurance can the Prime
Minister give that the government is
working hard to help prevent this type
of all too common despicable crime and
bring the perpetrators to books
well I'm I'm very sorry to hear about
Marie's case for my honorable friend
raises and I know how convincing
scammers can be and the upset and hurt
that they cause I'm pleased to reassure
my honorable friend that the government
will shortly be publishing our fraud
strategy which will establish a male
unified coordinated response from
government and law enforcement and the
private sector to block more scams and
to better protect the public we now
comes the leader of the opposition
Kirsten
thank you Mr Speaker his Home Secretary
says the Asylum system is broken
who broke it
well Mr Speaker let's let's just we can
look at the record on migration let's
look at it what did what did
what what did we on this side of the
house do we gave the British people a
referendum on brexit
we we delivered we delivered brexit we
ended the free movement of people Mr
Speaker that's our record on migration
policy it's not something The Honorable
gentleman supported he opposed it at
every turn and it's not what the British
people want
[Applause]
[Music]
no one wants open borders on this side
of the house they've lost control of
orders on their side of the house
speaker
cup four
four prime ministers in five years it's
the same old same old he stands there
and tries to pass the blame if the
Asylum system is broken and his lot have
been in power for 12 years how can it be
anyone's fault but theirs
[Applause]
speaker people rightly want to see us
getting a grip of migration in our
borders
let's look at the record let's look at
the record the right normal gentleman he
voted against the nationality and
borders bill
he said he he said he would scrap the
Rwanda partnership he opposed the ending
of free movement of people
[Applause]
issue that not only does the party
opposite not have a plan they have
opposed every single measure we
can't attack a plan if you don't have a
plan
we voted against it because we said it
wouldn't work and it hasn't worked he he
says he's getting a grip he's got a plan
so let's have a look at that plan the
Rwanda deal was launched in April it
cost the taxpayer 140 million pounds and
Rising the number of people deported to
Rwanda is zero since then 30 000 people
have crossed the channel in small bloat
it's not working is it he hasn't got a
grip
[Music]
[Applause]
Mr Speaker we on this side of the house
are clear that we want to defend our
borders when the shadow Home Secretary
this weekend was asked she couldn't
answer a simple question if the party
opposite was in favor of higher or lower
migration
and I when it comes to tackling our
migration reducing migration we are
see it's a blank page Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker blame others deflect attack
on something else so much the new age of
accountability
of all the people who arrived in small
boats last year how many Asylum claims
have been processed yeah
prime minister
Mr Speaker we do need we do need
Mr Speaker not enough is the answer very
straightforwardly not enough and that's
what we're going to fix but the only one
The Honorable gentleman raises this
question what do we do we've increased
the number of processing officials by 80
we are putting an extra 500 more by next
march but if he really if he really was
serious about fixing this problem then
he would acknowledge that we do need to
tackle the issue of people putting
Furious
Furious claims spurious repeated last
minute claims to frustrate the process
That's How we'll tackle the system so
why then did he vote against the
nationality and board attack which deals
with it
Mr Speaker he says he says not enough
you could say that again
four percent four percent of people
arriving in small boats last year had
their Asylum claim processed according
to the book is the Home Secretary has a
better chance of becoming the next story
leader than she has a processing and
Asylum claim in a year
and he talks about numbers they're only
taking half the number of Asylum
decisions that they're used to that's
why the system is broken 4
000 people at the manston Air Force Base
massively overcrowded all sorts of
diseases breaking out so did the Home
Secretary receive legal advice that she
should move people out yes or no prime
minister
Mr Speaker that the right honorable
gentleman is very fond of reminding us
that he used to be the former director
of public prosecutions so he knows the
government's policy on commenting on
legal advice but what I can say is a
significant action that the Home
Secretary has taken to fix the issue
since September 30 more hotels with four
and a half thousand new beds appointing
a senior General to control the
situation at manston and indeed
increasing the number of staff there by
almost a half Mr Speaker these are
significant steps to demonstrate that we
are getting a grip of this system but
this is a
always do it fairly and compassionately
because that's the right thing
Mr Speaker he talks about my time as
director of public prosecutions I
prosecuted people's Smugglers he can't
even get an asylum claim process
I think the answer to the question
whether Home Secretary received legal
advice to move people out of Marsden is
yes he just hasn't got the guts to say
it we he did a grubby deal with her
putting her in charge of Britain's
security just so he could Dodge an
election
she's broken the ministerial code lost
control of a refugee Center and put our
security at risk she did get one thing
right she finally admitted that the toys
have broken the Asylum system criminal
gangs running amok thousands crossing
the channel in small boats every week
hardly any claims process so why doesn't
he get a proper Home Secretary scrap the
Rwanda gimmick Crackdown on smuggling
gangs in the Small Boat Crossings speed
up Asylum claims and agree an
international deal start governing
Watson gets a drink
[Applause]
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker that the right the
right honorable gentle front laws come
and just calm it down a little I do want
to hear the replies you're covering your
mouth's not helpful to me or you come on
prime minister Mr Speaker the right
honorable gentleman rightly raised the
topic of National Security because it is
important but this is the person this is
the person who in 2019 told the BBC and
I quote I do think Jeremy corbyn would
make a great prime minister
let's let's remember Mr Speaker Mr
Speaker let's remember that National
Security agenda abolishing our Armed
Forces scrapping the nuclear deterrent
withdrawing from NATO voting against
every single anti-terror law we try
befriending Hamas and Hezbollah he may
want to forget about it but we will
remind him of it every week because it's
the conservative government that will
keep this country safe
[Music]
[Applause]
that's my register of interest Mr
Speaker right now we are suffering the
worst outbreak of avian flu ever
recorded hundreds of thousands of birds
are being destroyed to stem the spread
of this terrible disease the
government's acted quickly to bring
forward compensation to for live birds
called to 48 hours after confirmation of
disease but even this short delay is
causing significant losses to Farmers in
broadland as the disease wreaks Havoc to
flocks dead birds are not compensated
today is back British farming day will
my right honorable friend take this
opportunity to back British farmers and
agree compensation for all affected
birds from the date when disease is
confirmed prime minister well Mr Speaker
and someone who represents a very rural
informing Community it is a great
pleasure to back British farming day
enjoying with colleagues on all side of
the house in doing so but my honorable
friend is right to highlight that
outbreaks of avian flu this year are on
track to be some of the worst on record
that's why we've toughened up by
security measures on poultry farms and I
can say to him that we have confirmed we
will now pay compensation from the
outset of planned culling rather than at
the end a request that I know here in
the farming sector will warmly welcome
they did the SMP in Blackford
thank you Mr Speaker in May of this year
the new prime minister have told this
chamber and I quote
I can reassure the house that next
year's benefits will be operated by this
September CPI and the triple lock will
apply for the state pension but last
week the Prime Minister repeatedly
refused to see if he would keep to
promise that he made only five months
ago prime minister people don't need to
hear any more spin about compassionate
conservatism people just need a straight
answer to a simple question will he keep
his promise and lift benefits and
pensions in line with inflation Minister
well Mr Speaker we do now have an
excellent new Chancellor and I'm looking
forward to his Autumn statement in a
couple of weeks it wouldn't be right it
wouldn't be right to comment on
individual policy measures before then
but I think everyone knows we do phrase
a challenging economic Outlook and
difficult decisions will need to be made
but what I would say is that we will
always as my track record as Chancellor
demonstrates have fairness and
compassion at the heart of everything
[Applause]
well Mr Speaker it was a very simple
question asking for the prime minister
to reiterate what he promised just five
months ago for this second week running
he still won't give his straight answer
to the most vulnerable that requires
support the Prime Minister keeps telling
us that difficult decisions need to be
made but austerity 2.0 isn't a difficult
decision it is what it has always been a
Tory political choice
in the week that BP saw quarterly
profits of 7.1 billion pounds why not
take the easy decision to bring any
proper windfall tax why not take the
easy decision to reinstate the cap on
Bankers bonuses why not take the easy
decision to scrap the non-dome tax
avoidance and with all that new Revenue
why not stand up today and take the
easiest decision of all to protect those
most in need and increase benefits and
pensions in line with inflation
[Music]
raised the issue of North Sea and this
is a point of significant difference
between his party and ours as Chancellor
I introduced the new levy on oil and gas
companies because I believe that was the
right thing to do but where we will
always differ is we believe that our
naughty producers do have an important
role to play in our transition to Net
Zero they are an important source of
transition fuels and we will make sure
that we support them to invest in
exploiting those resources
thank you Mr Speaker can I personally
welcome the ipu delegation for
Madagascar who in today's
new Academy
more locally I'm delighted that next
year open reach will be rolling out
Ultra fast Broadband in wigginton in my
constituency but other rural areas of
Southwest Hertfordshire light does well
are still in dire need of better
connectivity can the Prime Minister
update the house on the progress of the
five billion pound project gigabits
prime minister
absolutely right to recognize the role
of broadband in providing leveling up
opportunities across our economy that's
why we invested 5 billion pounds in
Project gigabit and now we have 71 of UK
premises having access to this from just
five percent uh when we came into office
I'm very pleased to tell honorable
friend that we will be launching a
procurement to provide Google bit
coverage for his area in the coming
weeks
thank you Mr Speaker the Prime Minister
will know that it's Scotland's energy
resources that feed corporate profits
and keep his Majesty's treasury pumped
full of cash to the tune of 8 billion
pounds in the last nine months alone in
return candidates in the summertory
leadership contests tried to outdo each
other in their content and hostility to
Scotland's democracy so without falling
back on that you've had your vote Trope
can the Prime Minister tell me is
Scotland in a voluntary and respectful
Union of equals as claimed in 2014 or
are we hostages at a territorial British
colony
Mr Speaker what what people across
Scotland rightly want to see is both
their governments working constructively
together to improve their lives that's
what we will do on this side of the
house and part of that is actually
supporting Scottish energy producers
which he is right have a vital role to
play in enabling our transition to Net
Zero and improving our energy security
and those Scottish companies will have
our full support Scott Benson thank you
Mr Speaker
[Music]
nearly 40 000 illegal immigrants have
crossed the channel so far this year
Landing taxpayers with a hotel bill of
5.6 million pounds per day to
accommodate them is it anyone that that
millions of people in this country are
furious with the situation prime
minister during the summer you set out a
comprehensive 10-point plan to tackle
this issue everybody on this side of a
chamber wants you to succeed in this aim
when can we expect the firm action the
British people
[Music]
well Mr Speaker I know I know this issue
is rightly a priority for my honorable
friend it's a priority for his
constituents and I can reassure them
that it is a priority for me and this
government too whether it's the
nationalities and borders act all the
further measures we are planning to take
we will defend our borders stop the
illegal Crossings and ensure that there
is fairness and compassion in our system
that is the way to restore trust and
that is what his constituents and the
British people deserve Stone yeah here
here
speak up I have a constituent who is
Supermarket worker she's paid four
weekly because she receives one double
salary payment there's one month of the
year where she receives no Universal
Credit normally not an issue Mr speaker
however because Universal Credit is
linked to the cost of living payment my
constituency now no longer qualifies for
the 320 pounds that could see her
through the very worst of a cold handed
winter sure what could the Prime
Minister do to mend this Gap in the cost
of living support
prime minister
Mr Speaker what I can tell the honorable
gentleman is we also provide a
discretionary funding which was provided
through Barnett to the Scottish
government especially to deal with cases
like the one that he raised but it'd be
very happy if he wants to write to us
for the constituents details to look
into it the discretionary funding was
made available especially for cases like
that
thank you Mr
one of my one of my surgeries in broxtow
by my constituent Aaron Halsey in his
arms was his three-week old newborn baby
Tim Aaron's wife Bernadette tragically
passed away whilst giving birth to Tim
Aaron came to see me regarding the
disparity that exists over chair
parental leave the current eligibility
requirements differ between that of the
surviving birthing partner
as compared to the surviving
non-birthing partner and this meant in
Aaron's case he was not entitled to
leave to raise his son with the Prime
Minister ensure that both my constituent
and I can meet with the relevant
minister to make sure that we move
towards a future where parents are not
in this position prime minister well I
know I know the whole house will join me
in extending our condolences to Aaron
following the tragic loss of his wife
and I thank my honorable friend for
raising this issue employed parents can
benefit from statutory support depending
on personal circumstances I'm very
concerned to hear that that is not
happening in this case and I will of
course ensure that he gets a meeting
with a relevant Minister as soon as
possible to resolve this issue
that will they PM join me in condemning
opaquely funded so-called think tax who
exerts so much influence on gullible
politicians that their policies were
able to almost crash the UK economy just
weeks ago open democracy reports a
former member of the charity commission
has a board has called for The Institute
of economic Affairs to be stripped of
its charitable status saying the very
purpose of the iaea shrinking the state
is political is it right this body
receives charitable tax status and will
the PM meet with me to discuss the
influence bodies such as the aea exert
our politicians including what part what
influence they still have with him
well Mr Speaker obviously charitable
status is massively for a matter for the
Charities commission but more generally
actually do believe in free speech and
vibrant debate of ideas that is a good
thing and we should do absolutely
nothing to stamp it out even when we
disagree with it
Louis thank you Mr Speaker in the run-up
to the Autumn statement will my right
honorable friend do everything he can to
persuade the chancellor to assist those
people who took out mortgages in good
faith and now are at risk of losing
their homes through unaffordable
increases prime minister well Mr Speaker
my honorable friend is absolutely right
to raise mortgage payments it's why it
is absolutely crucial that we put our
public finances on a sustainable footing
to limit the increase in interest rates
because ultimately that is what puts
pressure on people's mortgage payments
that's what this government is
determined to do and in the short term
there are of support available through
the welfare system for those with
mortgage payments and I hope he can
direct his constituent today
here thank you Mr Speaker given the
continued Russian invasion and the now
legal annexation of parts of Ukraine
will the Prime Minister recommit his
government to pursuing the full and
proper accountability including through
the international criminal court of
those who violate international law in
territories that they occupy and in
particular will he pursue the rigorous
application of the Fourth Geneva
Convention in terms of the treatment of
Civilian populations in militarily
occupied areas
gentleman for his question which is
absolutely right I can't confirm we will
continue with the policy that the
previous government put in place and I
think it's something that we can be
proud of that we provided I think the
earliest technical support to gather
evidence to put cases together for
future prosecutions at the ICC we'll
continue to gather evidence Provide
support to the ukrainians because he's
absolutely right what we are hearing is
abhorrent it's wrong and those that who
are conducting these things must be held
to account Simon Hall thank you Mr
Speaker and I both represent rural
constituencies and he will know the
difficulty in securing both NHS
dentistry and GPS in rural areas we on
this side of the house know that the
financial decisions that he and the
Chance are going to be taking are going
to be tough
notwithstanding that can I urge you to
ensure that there's many initiatives as
possible can be supported and put in
place in order to make sure the GPS and
dentists know that working in rural
areas is an attractive place and to
encourage their Recruitment and
Retention prime minister my my honorable
friend is absolutely right about the
importance of Health Care provision in
rural areas which our constituents feel
acutely because of the distances they
have to travel uh he has my Assurance we
will continue to prioritize both
dentistry and GP recruitment to make
sure that everyone in this country has
access to the primary health care that
they need and deserve
thank you thank you Mr Speaker
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
with the highest peacetime tax rates
food inflation running at 11.6 mortgage
rates Rising dramatically and a 50
billion pound hole in the public
finances the Prime Minister knows that
Britain's broke
what is it about the 12 years of Tory
Rule and five years of him as a minister
that has made such a mess of Britain
[Music]
Mr Speaker when it when it comes to the
economy The Honorable gentleman just
failed to mention the single biggest
cause of the challenges that we face
right now which is
which is absolutely the off the
aftermath of a global pandemic which has
affected Supply chains across the world
and an illegal War being conducted by
Putin which is leading to high energy
prices these are the root cause of the
challenges we are facing the challenges
we are facing are Global in nature it is
wrong to say that they are particular to
this country now and we will of course
do what we always do on this side of the
house deliver a strong economy for the
British people
thank you Mr Speaker in last Summer's
Heat Wave people across Essex witnessed
terrible fires and last month in
Ethiopia I witnessed the horrific
climate change driven drought that is
forcing millions of people across the
Horn of Africa to the brink of famine
I've discussed climate change with my
right honorable friend I know he cares
and it's great that he's going to show
my shake but we the UK brought the world
to Glasgow for cop 26 it's vital that we
remain world leaders on climate change
so please confirm this government will
fulfill the promises that we the UK made
in Glasgow yes well can I thank my
honorable friend for her work and role
that she has played in us championing
the fight against climate change and I
agree with her there is no long-term
Prosperity without action on climate
change and there is no energy security
without investment in Renewables that's
why I will attend cop 27 next week to
deliver to deliver Mr Speaker on
glasgow's Legacy of building a secure
clean and sustainable future
thank you Mr Speaker while the Prime
Minister was secretly recorded boasting
to friends that he had helped divert
money away from deprived areas like
Coventry towards wealthy areas staff of
coventry's Hospital are still paying 600
pounds a year to pass at work so when
will the Prime Minister stop hammering
working people in my community
well uh Mr Speaker I think the honor
related was asking about car parking in
NHS hospitals if I'm understood O'Reilly
we did introduce temporary free car
parking during the pandemic that was the
right thing to do and now all NHS NHS
trusts that charge for parking have
implemented our free parking Manifesto
commitment for those in the greatest
need including hard-working NHS staff
who work overnight
speaker on back British farming day will
the Prime Minister recognize with all
members of the House the important role
that farmers take and recognize that
public money for public good means
producing food in this country but could
he also recognize the value that our
trade deals are doing in allowing us to
export our high quality produce around
the world in particular the Australia
agreement where a member of this house
will be able to enjoy a certain delicate
cut in his Bush tracker top tiles
yeah
well uh Mr Speaker I agree with my
honorable friend a British Farmers r d
the lifeblood of our nation I join him
in celebrating their contribution I
agree with him we need to prioritize
food security and he is right to
Champion free trade Deals they open up
new markets and new opportunities for
Great British produce and we will
continue to open up more markets for our
Farmers everywhere
Mr Speaker can I welcome the first uh
prime minister from your from Yorkshire
for a very long time but I'm trying to
be kind to him this morning
isn't it the fact that since he resigned
as chance to check on the filter we've
had the most turbulent economic and
political disaster in our country that
any of us can remember and when it when
he reflects on that would he also think
why when he was the chance of exchequer
he did not help ordinary working people
as well as he could
yeah
and while we're can you now take the
opportunity to tax the non-doms who had
70 000 of them that are getting away
with avoiding tax and Willie ringing
attacks on Winslow profits on the gas
and Island Prime Minister
look Mr Speaker I'm very proud of my
record as Chancellor in this country
and and maybe maybe that Andre agenda
could talk to the 10 million people who
had their job saved through furlough
maybe he could talk to the millions of
those on the lowest incomes who
benefited from the changes we've made to
Universal Credit this will always be a
fair and compassionate government that
has the most vulnerable at our hearts
thank you
thank you Mr Speaker with only two out
of ten uh autistic adults currently in
employment it's clear that much more
needs to be done to realize their
potential well my right honorable friend
work with me to make sure that business
and industry help close that alarming
employment gap well I I know this this
is an error that my right novel friend
at rightly Champions and knows an
enormous amount about I look forward to
working with him closely to get his
recommendations on how we and Industry
can improve the lives of those who need
our help Sarah Jones yeah thank you Mr
Speaker the leader of the opposition
asked the Prime Minister who broke the
Asylum system he dodged the question
yeah yeah the truth Mr Speaker is that
the backlog is now so great decision
making so collapsed and returns so low
at a tenth of what they used to be that
the criminal gangs have a business model
to die for whose fault is that
[Applause]
Mr Speaker the reason we are in this
situation is because of the
unprecedented number of people arriving
here illegally often from safe third
countries now if the party opposite was
really serious about this they would
realize that we have to stop illegal
migration that we have to stop the
exploitation of vulnerable people abroad
but they have opposed every single
measure we have taken they're not
serious about this problem because they
don't think it matters
very much Mr Speaker both myself and
many of my constituents remember fondly
the prime ministers visited Ipswich when
he was a chance to fix jacket we spoke
about leveling up and he made it clear
to me leveling up isn't just about one
part of the country it's a national
Mission Barefoot does the Prime Minister
agree but a great way to show people
elliptitrus we're being supported by
leveling up fun bit to get Ipswich
active 18 million pounds 50 million
pounds for games for sorts over three
million pounds for the outdoor leader in
broomhill
well Mr speaker model friend is Right
leveling up is about spreading
opportunity in every part of our United
Kingdom ensuring people have pride in
the place they call home I look forward
to seeing his leveling up fun bid and I
know it will be being considered over
the course of this year and I wish him
every success that completes prime
minister's questions
just let just let it
well there we go prime minister's
questions only the second one for the
Prime Minister uh let's bring in our
political editor Beth Rigby is here and
and Beth perhaps no surprise that that
immigration and the migration issues on
the south coast in in particular were
very much at the heart of what the labor
party and kirstama went for against Mr
sunac today yeah absolutely no surprise
that Jane it has been hasn't it the big
problem in the early days of his
administration uh with that emergency
statement to the House of Commons by the
Home Secretary explaining both why she
had leaked or sent sorry documents via
her personal email half a dozen time
breaching uh ministerial code she had to
go and explain that and then obviously
this developing and worrying situation
in manston in that detent one not to
take that processing center where it has
appeared that thousands of people have
been kept there for more than 24 hours
uh breaking legal duties by the
government and the role of the Home
Secretary in processing or not
processing people now immigration is
typically an area where labor have not
felt strong on
not least because of their position on
brexit
and immigration controls it's
traditionally been quite a strong
position for the conservatives but not
today you what you saw there was a prime
minister being absolutely hammered on
immigration policy Kirsten are really
going uh for Rishi sunac on matters of
immigration he criticized him over the
processing of claims
at that point there was an admission
from Rishi sunak that there hasn't been
enough processing of claims he said not
enough claims have been processed of
people coming over in small boats you
know there's record numbers this year 40
000 people already and it's not even at
the end of the year the prime minister's
saying it's not enough and we are going
to fix that and Care starmer coming back
with that repost there saying he can say
that again four percent of those who
arrived in small boats uh their claims
have been processed in the past year he
then asked on this very tricky question
for swella bravaman on whether she did
or did not ignore legal advice
given to her about the need to find
accommodation for migrants that were
staying in that Center that should have
been processed and put into other
accommodation we found out that they
haven't that they people have been
staying there for weeks in overcrowded
conditions with outbreaks of diseases
reports today about people trying to
Fashion weapons and and all sorts of
potential unrest that we picked up
and has been reported on Sky News uh
kirstama asking directly whether or not
the Home Secretary ignored legal advice
yes or no the Prime Minister duck in
that question saying you know government
policies that we don't comment on legal
advice kirstalmer saying I think that's
because the answer is yes and I have to
say Jane I have two sources both telling
me home office sources
that that advice
was ignored or maybe it was rejected but
it wasn't accepted now I have to say the
Home Secretary on record in the House of
Commons and says I did not ignore legal
advice but the point of all of this is
that labor have clearly taken decision
that this is a running problem this is
an open wound for Rishi sunak in terms
of the early days of his Premiership and
they're really hammering at home and for
Rishi sunak I think he gave quite a kind
of Spirited performance though I mean he
does manage project confidence at the
dispatch box but in terms of the
questions around policy that was really
uncomfortable for him and it is hard of
it for him isn't it you know the labor
party are able to say you've been in
power for 12 years your own home
secretary has admitted that the Asylum
system is broken whose fault is it and
and Richie's thing about coming back you
know as you say kierstama pushing you
know you've got to crack down on gangs
you've got to speed up Asylum claims
British is your next response to that
one was well let me take you back to
things you've said and and bringing up
Jeremy corbyn there'll be some who will
say you can't deflect I mean questions
of that nature I mean the two the two
defense lines that Rishi sunak had there
was you didn't vote for legislation that
we think would have tightened border
controls uh of course because of
everything that's going on and the
admission by the Home Secretary that the
system is broken uh that is not a
particularly effective defense for a
prime minister but it's all he's got in
that moment
um in terms of the corbyn attack line
what's happening in terms of kind of
political attack lines between these two
men now is that kirstarma
is bringing up this issue of The Grubby
dealers he puts it between Rishi sunak
and swella bravman the position that the
leader of the opposition is trying to
make is that you put the uh you
reappointed a Home Secretary for
political reasons when there were
reasons around conduct and reasons about
competence that that person shouldn't
have been put back in the pace so this
is The Grubby deal now
response to that as you said Jane is to
say well you're the guy that said Jeremy
corbyn was going to be a great prime
minister and I'm going to keep reminding
you of that now you could argue that
because
um Jeremy corbyn's not even a member of
the labor but I mean he's been he's lost
the whip
um that that is a blunt attack line but
I think that what is going on there is
the conservative party obviously
realized that that is a weakness
potentially with voters for kirstarma
this is the guy that wanted a second
referendum this is the guy uh that
wanted Jeremy corbyn to be prime
minister when lots and lots of Voters
did not so I think it's in a reasonable
attack line
um I think the bigger issue for him is
that he has a massive policy problem on
small boats uh it was exacerbated
potentially by uh the remarks Liz trust
said about President macron while she
was prime minister as a friend or Faye
well we'll see that's not helpful if
you're if you're trying to do a d feel
and I think there's other issues going
on with Rishi sunak at the moment
there's two things I would point out one
uh he's u-turned again today so he says
he's not going to cop
this is the um the climate change
conference uh in Egypt he says he's not
going because of domestic policies that
is quite controversial Boris Johnson
then confirms last night in an interview
in Sky News that he is going and this
morning uh Rishi sunak is going so again
you get this feeling of sorry this is
meant to be about stability these are
u-turns I think the other thing that I
would have picked up in prime minister's
questions there was he was asked by the
Westminster leader of the SMP Ian
Blackford about the pensions triple lock
now this is a prime minister he won the
steps of number 10 and in prime
minister's questions last week said I am
sticking to 2019 Manifesto commitments
that is a conservative party
um reason to govern or mandate not a
Boris Johnson mandate there my words not
his
and it and in primus's questions
obviously the triple lock so you will
commit to lifting pensions by inflation
if it's the highest figure of wages two
percent or inflation and it is obviously
very high at the moment will he commit
to lifting by inflation he would not
commit again in prime minister's
questions saying it would not be right
to comment on individual policy measures
before the Autumn statement he said I
think everyone knows we do face
challenging economic Outlook and
difficult decisions will need to be made
and then he said I would say as
Chancellor my character's Chancellor
demonstrates fairness and compassion in
everything we do now maybe that's a hint
that he will but again
stick to what you said you would do if
it was a Manifesto commitment why is it
difficult and you said you're going to
stick to that why not just commit to
that now Liz trusted it two weeks ago
for the for the for the viewer for the
pensioner it might feel like a
government flip-flopping uh at a time
when what was she seen that really needs
to do is Project competence and
stability certainty Beth thanks very
much